[Musik]
hallo herr zusammen zufällig will heute
möchte ich euch meinen zweiten kanal
vorstellen und zwar verlief picknick
kanal
nein nicht der technik von landtechnik
kanal wenn der techniker leider
deswegen nehme ich das ganze selber in
die haben wahrscheinlich was kann ich
mir unter fälliges technikwelt
vorstellen und zwar weil ich hier auf
meinem verließ live kanal immer mal
wieder gefragt
kelly die benutzt man diese
küchenmaschine oder fälle was gibt's für
produkte kannst du mal einen notruf ab
besten kannst du mir sagen welchen
hochleistungs mich verwenden kannst du
mir sagen welche bügeleisen ich
verwenden muss welche waschmaschine
spülmaschine oder welchen backofen nicht
mehr kaufen wollen und natürlich da und
wird euch natürlich gerne die fragen
beantworten aber das alles passt einfach
nicht hier auf meinen hauptkanal
auffällig wenn ihr auffällig welt geht
es um fette es geht um zutaten es geht
um änderungen essen trinken kuchen
torten backen dekorieren es geht um
familienleben um alltagstipps und
natürlich auch um die fans videos und
hier auch meine kanal geht's nicht um
rezepte das heißt wenn sie ein rezept
video erstellen dann geht einfach um
rezept an sich und natürlich verwende
ich auch meine hilfsmittel also meiner
küchenmaschinen und meine hilfsgeräte
aber die stehen jetzt nicht im
vordergrund sondern sie auch gar nicht
denn sie helfen mir einfach nur bei der
arbeit und erleichtern mit den alltag
aber natürlich kommt dann immer mal
wieder fragen von euch und ihr fragt
mich einfach danach was kann ich denn
alles mit zulegen was kann ich mich eine
küchenmaschine kaufen welche passt
vielleicht zu mir und ganzen habe ich
immer bis halb privat beantwortet über
e-mail zum beispiel um einfach auf ihre
individuellen bedürfnisse einzugehen
und jetzt habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen meinen technik kanal
verließ technikwelt begründen und dort
auch die videos zu machen damit eben
auch alle was davon haben
das heißt jeder der sich für die technik
für die küchengeräte für haushaltsgeräte
oder auch für keine produkte
interessiert kann einfach doch
vorbeischauen und nicht dort keinen
videos eben anschauen
jeder hat seinen eigenen lebensstil und
seine eigene art und weise sich zu
ernähren
und deswegen kann es sein dass gewisse
produkte bei mir in meinem haushalt
passen aber eben bei euch nicht passen
und genauso andere form dass gewisse
produkte zu euch passen aber eben nicht
zu mir ich würde zum beispiel auch öfter
mal nach einer getreidemühle gefragt für
diejenigen zum beispiel die eine
glutenunverträglichkeit haben oder die
bewusst einfach ihr eigenes korn selber
malen möchten und selbst mehr zubereiten
möchten ist diese anschaffung wirklich
gold wert und auch sehr sinnvoll
bei mir zuhause ich brauche einfach
nicht weil ich jetzt man nicht selber
malen möchte zumindest zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht das heißt für den
einen ist es wirklich sinnvoll und
empfehlenswert für den anderen
vielleicht nicht und auf meine technik
kanal werde ich auch produkte testen und
euch vorstellen ich werde schauen wie
sie funktioniert und auch vielleicht zum
ersten mal selbst ausprobieren und euch
dann einfach meine meinung und meine
erfahrung mitgeben
und dort wo es einfach auch darum gehen
ist vom produkt soffin voll ist
vielleicht nicht sinnvoll
braucht man überhaupt oder ist es
wirklich überflüssig es gibt wirklich
produkte wie sand am meer und man könnte
sich jeden tag auch mal ist kaufen oder
in die küche stellen aber oftmals sollte
man bitte einfach vor dem kauf gut
informieren gut beraten lassen und vor
allem einfach hinterfragen brauchen
überhaupt oder ist es einfach wirklich
überflüssig
auch bei uns was zum beispiel so wir
haben ja bis vor kurzer zeit keine
kaffeemaschine weil mein mann der mutter
verschwand bis sparsam bagdad immer
geistig wahl schwabe
aber das ist jetzt nicht das thema
werden keine kaffeemaschine und dann hat
er mich unbedingt gewünscht einen
siebträger das heißt wo man einfach den
kaffee selber nochmal in muss die
kaffeebohnen damit ganze pressen und
polieren muss und dann eben die den
kaffee eben selbst zubereitet geplant
aber leider nicht hinbekommen und das
war einfach viel zu mühselig und der
kaffee hat auch wirklich nicht vor ganz
gut geschmeckt weil der moment eben auch
kein kaffee experte ist das heißt von
der kaffeemaschine und die träger ist
einfach etwas für jemanden der sich gut
damit auskennt und wirklich das ganze
auch lebt das heißt er steht dann da und
möchte morgen fünf minuten mit dem café
verbringen und nicht wie ich zum
beispiel einfach auf den knopf drücken
und den kaffee eben mal kurz bringen
deswegen gibt es bei uns mittlerweile
den kaffeevollautomaten mit dem ich
zufrieden bin aber das ist einfach meine
erfahrung wir mussten das produkt
natürlich erst einmal selber testen um
dann festzustellen es doch nicht für uns
und jetzt haben wir uns eben für den
kaffeevollautomaten entschieden
und solche fragen und erfahrungsberichte
sich auch zb immer auf facebook in
verschiedenen gruppen und da werde ich
immer mal wieder gefragt nach produkten
nach bestimmten zubehörteilen zum
beispiel für kennwort und tipps.net
maschinen und da werden auch viele
fragen gesammelt
ich habe da auch mal die ganzen gruppen
administratoren gefragt manchmal finden
die häufigsten fragen und die habe ich
es einfach gesammelt und als video
zusammengefasst und eben auf meinem
technik kanal werden die dann eben
demnächst alle hochgeladen
aber eines country vor ich hab's
probiert dort morath und finde ich auch
ganz gute laune dann in den videos nur
so leicht aus ja aber leider war es doch
nicht sein appell ich habe alles
probiert ich habe einfach probiert die
kaffeebohnen getauscht bitte alles alles
auf diesen druck und hat einfach nicht
geklappt aber hat uns einfach gezeigt
siebträgermaschine ist ja immer so
können andere menschen einfache den
italiener und überlassen auf jeden fall
ja jedenfalls war mir die fragen
gesammelt und auch schon ganz viele
videos gedreht und wir werden jetzt
einfach nach und nach dort hochgeladen
und ihr könnt mir gerne auch dort auf
meinem technikwelt kanal einfach die
kommentare hinterlassen fragen
hinterlassen und ich werde versuchen
einfach auf alle fragen einzugehen und
verschiedenes zu testen
ich habe zum beispiel dem stabmixer mit
akku betrieben das heißt ohne kabel
ich kann mich frei in der küche bewegen
damit ist es sinnvoll für andere ist ein
kabel sinnvoller weil andere vielleicht
vergessen wird akkuladegerät immer
aufzuladen er den akku aufzuladen ich
mich natürlich auf der erfassung ja das
ist mein stab mich in meinem agenten
vielleicht nicht weil er immerhin konnte
ordentlich aber ich mache euch angst
schon verstaut
im gegenzug dazu haben wir zum beispiel
und stabmixer mit kabel was bei mir
jetzt nicht mit dem fall wäre denn in
meiner jetzigen küche habe ich nur eine
steckdose hier und könnte zum beispiel
in einem topf drinnen gar nicht frieren
oder verrühren weil wird er gar nicht
auf aber es gibt manche leute die kommen
nämlich aus gablenberg das problem ist
immer wenn man akku betrieben hat und
mal sind starke braucht ist jedes mal
der akku leer
kann man ja zum glück noch nicht darauf
zu achten oder die haben wir zum
beispiel zwei kandidaten habe ich einen
slot user das heißt der presse darf ganz
langsam aus obst und gemüse heraus ganz
schonend und hier habe ich einen power
plus blender der 3,5 ps das heißt
gegensätzlicher können die zwei
maschinen gar nicht sein und in der
werbung wird eben oft gesagt mensch der
eine bereitete ganz ohne große städte
fällen nicht der andere speise zu leicht
fallen und filme auf und ich frag mich
dann immer stimmt ist alles und was ist
richtig
braucht man das überhaupt oder möchte
man einfach nur wissen was weckesser
wohl kann ich oder kann ich einen apfel
becken genau ganz vorbei ist wir haben
über die millionenshow überhaupt als zu
werden ich weiß es auch nicht nur die
hatten keine sloothaak einem flug mit
einem stabmixer und keine maschine auf
hohen tieren
er machte mal links der macht zb in
coolen sachen mobile saftpresse was aus
und der recht der kamera selbst wieder
umdrehungen dass es sogar das gemixte
erhitzt dass ich sogar im freiminuten
heiße suppe trinken kann ohne dafür
erhebt nur allein mit dem reibung und es
dann einfach bewachen die ich dann auch
meine technik kanal euch vorstellen wäre
captain werde und an euch ebenso ein
paar tipps tricks und rezepte natürlich
auch eingeladen
oder kann ich beim slow cooker aber nie
gesehen habe kann ich nicht so gut auch
benutzen wird muss schnell gehen muss
solche fragen natürlich die fragen die
uns durch den kopf gehen genau
also falls ihr euch jetzt auch für diese
themen interessiert könnt ihr gerne auf
meinem neuen kanal kellys technikwelt
und könnt ihr auch gerne komponieren
dann bei dem auf dem neuesten stand und
natürlich wirklich hier auf meinem
youtube kanal als auffällig sei es
weiterhin alles um leckere kuchen torten
und gebäck um herzhaftes zu drehen und
um mit anderer und um rat natürlich auch
das war schon bei süßen
das ist mal richtig lieb gemacht und für
alle anderen die sich eben dafür
interessieren können gerne auch bei den
neuen auf den zweiten biotop kanal
gefallen und da gibt er bald ganz viele
tolle videos bis zum nächsten mal
hallo herzlich willkommen auch wenn die
technik kanal deshalb leider nicht
mitgedacht weil es ganz genau auf dieses
licht immer so schwer ausgeht man musste
in diesem winkel sprechen umgesetzt
werden
wenn du denn da anfangs noch vereine
zahnbürste und aufbau und karrubi war
eigentlich brauche ich gar keine schiffe
oder und techniker na ja so kennen die
leute nicht bestätigen